for reaction to what you saw author and
columnist mark Stein joins us mark that
conversation got me thinking about she
asked I thought actually pretty good
question which is why do people dislike
Hillary Clinton so much and I think I
actually thought about it because
Hillary is not the most offensive on
policy among all Democrats but she
grates why is that and I think it's
because there's this weird thing that
she does where she sells herself as a
very strong figure and I think she is
tough actually it's the thing one thing
I like about her and then when attacked
immediately retreats into the victim
pose you can't say that I'm a woman
you're sexist and you just sort of think
that's unfair that that's not good
sportsmanship like pick one are you
ferocious and tough or you weaken
persecuted does that bother you yep yeah
I think that's actually the problem but
that duality as it were I think derives
from her role she's not only someone in
who's a politician in her own right but
she was also for many years and this is
how she came to national prominence the
spouse of a prominent politician and I
think that's really I think that's the
difference when you look at I was I was
struck by the subtitle of Jennifer
parmie Airy's book an open letter to the
women who will run the world
well actually outside the Democrat Party
and outside America women do won a lot
of the world I don't happen to agree
with them I mean ankylo Merkel is
single-handedly wrecked Europe by
letting in millions of phony-baloney
refugees Theresa May is going all super
wobbly on brexit but what they're not is
the wife of the previous guy which
doesn't pass the smell test and you
can't shatter the glass ceiling when
you're doing this latin american ava
parantha that's such a good point
but shouldn't it be shouldn't it be
off-limits just as a matter of fairness
to pose as someone who's tough and
decisive and then when questioned as you
would question anybody who seeks to have
power over you whip around and accuse
the person of bias for asking a
conventional question like that that
shouldn't be allowed
no and again I think that I think what's
interesting to me is that the rest of
the world has moved way beyond this so
all this our talk about how how the
America America is uniquely sexist
I know I've sat in the Australian
Parliament during Prime Minister's
question time and watch Julia Gillard a
Labour Prime Minister who I don't happen
to agree with and Julia Julie Bishop the
deputy leader of Her Majesty's loyal
opposition at that time clobbering each
other back and forth and neither of them
would say if it all goes wrong they
don't say oh stop beating up on me I'm a
woman the fact is this is this
disastrous investment in Hillary Clinton
to go back to what you've been talking
about on the rest of the show sorry I
mentioned this on your show a couple of
months back and I think it's an
important point the reason one reason
the party has gone left is because
Democratic centrists were represented by
the kleptocrat Clinton's force oh yes so
if you're if you're in the Democrat
Party and you don't want to feel dirty
because the Clintons are in it for
themselves of opportunists they're
running this rotten charity which is
basically there to provide them with a
head of state lifestyle when the public
declines to make them heads of state if
you're if you're a Democrat that the
left is the CLE is the comparatively
close totally right it's totally right
they discredited by their sleaziness
centrist politics that's a very smart
point which I'd never thought and I
think you're actually that has huge
repercussions and yes pommie Ariat to be
addressing that instead of
condescendingly telling the rest of the
world that that hillary is the future
because that ain't true very smart Mark
Steyn as always thank you thanks a lot
Tucker